hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I'm Geo
and I'm Bart
and today I want to talk about something
super CUNY I was randomly scrolling on
uh Instagram specifically reels and um
you know how real just kind of curates
what you're going to see depending on
what you like interact and engage with
yeah so um I guess I interact with
kid content and parent content yeah I do
I don't know why I said I guess I do and
this account popped up and the account
is dad to try I haven't I don't know
this person's name yet but it's it's a
guy and it looks like he's he's sitting
at a desk and he does like podcast style
but it's just him by himself and he'll
talk about like cool shows that your
kids should be watching you know he's
like if you like Coco melon then you'll
also like you know the Tabitha Brown
show or whatever like he does
um a lot of family and and relationship
and
um specific to nurturing and raising
healthy balanced kids
and I thought it was so cool because he
has like this really cool like hipster
like Look to Him
um and one of the things that he was
talking about he goes if you want to
maintain a healthy relationship I highly
recommend that you ask these these three
questions to your significant
significant other every week all every
week every week okay so this is how he
phrased it I guess he was an athlete at
some point I don't know where he got it
from I didn't dive too deep into it but
I just heard the concept and I'm like oh
this is really cool
um so one of them is
um I want you to answer where is my home
run
oh right this week what was my home run
um what was my base hit and where did I
strike out wow yeah so again this
pertains to relationships so he's saying
like
um for home run like what did I kill it
at this week like what was something
that I knocked it out of the
park like how did I do something that I
share about myself and you share about
yourself no or I share about you and you
share about me correct oh yeah because
then we get to celebrate our wins so the
other person is the Umpire yes karacha
uh well the coach the other person is
the coach well the Umpire right like
like because if you you can think you
had a home run but it was like no that
was not a home run you struck out
actually
okay sure whatever I don't know baseball
like that fine no no but I'm trying to
say like am I going this is what I'm
proud of myself or your evaluating might
be I'm evaluating your behavior you're
evaluating my business yes you're the
Umpire okay cool
um and then base hit meaning like what
am I consistent at like what did what is
something that I'm just always like just
moving it one notch at a time
consistently killing that like you know
that I'm good at that thing oh okay wow
that's a really cool question yeah yeah
and then the final is where did I struck
out like how did I like this week where
did I drop the ball okay you go with me
no I just told you you go first me go
first yes
so this week lucky for us this is a
Friday
um yeah this week what are you tell me I
go first you said yeah you answer for me
yeah so you go first so what did you hit
a home run at yes and I said lucky for
you we've seen a whole week yeah because
today's Friday yeah yeah uh home run I
guess a business week
um what did I kill it at this week
this week I would say you killed it at
um
Mommy
what does that mean
um well I think you did a
so I think every week especially during
this transitional period we're trying to
make you a full-time mom we only have a
few moments to kind of like do what we
really want to do to kind of move the
needle in our family so to speak
and so uh and this week
um you took taika to jiu jitsu two times
on uh Monday and Tuesday basketball
Wednesday
Jiu Jitsu again on Thursday I went with
you guys on yesterday
um we were able to get taika desk
we're able to have like have enough pep
talks where
um he had a couple of good Jiu Jitsu
sessions
and we also got him some snacks so he
felt keoni and we also uh you also
helped him get his English his math
um like all of that and so to me I think
in terms of the week I would say in
terms of momming where there's a good
balance like CUNY Time Sports time
academics time but also bless you but
also like nurturing him enough to have
free time because every time he gets
free times like yeah you know he gets to
watch for a movie or whatever I think it
felt pretty like well-rounded this week
and
um
yeah loves his noodles and it's hearty
he got veggies you got meat so just
nutrition just everything across the
board
um and the CUNY like bad times where it
doesn't feel like a rush because
sometimes maybe skip bedtime story
because we have to we just gotta get you
in bed because we can't have you having
seizures I think really good
thank you okay I'll go
if you have any questions about that
uh do I agree with that this is stuff
that I'm just entertaining on my own
yeah but I'm thinking out loud
um well thank you for recognizing that
those are things I don't really pay
attention to because I'm just like
trying to get it done because right now
uh we're working with trying to wean him
off his medications and we've been
successful now that where we've dropped
what is it like one
yeah one milligram
um of one of the medications that he's
on and that's a huge win for us because
it's not like we have to add another
medication or try to find a different
medication so that's a huge win
so whatever we're doing we're doing the
right thing but the right thing right
now is making sure that he gets
sufficient amount of sleep which then
translates to if he doesn't take a nap
in the middle of a day which he can't
because he's at school he's not in
preschool so they don't take naps in
kindergarten anymore
so because you can't take the nap during
the middle of the day we move up his
sleeping from 9 00 P.M to 8 pm
so that means when he gets home uh like
yesterday for example he had an hour
later practice so we got home at
six
so that leaves only an hour honestly
only like 20 30 minutes to do homework
and eat and then he has to go take a
shower do the bedtime routine which is
drink his milk read the story lather his
little body up because it's so
goddamn dry in Las Vegas and he's he's
cracking all over the place like his
Skin's so ashy
so I don't ever really get to like slow
down and think about it and just like
Pat myself on the back like you did
great mom you know yeah it's more like
oh okay we gotta get it I don't
want you to get seizure go go go
but I don't want you to fall behind me
it's cool go but I don't want you to
fall behind and be Jersey go
so yeah I don't really get to like think
about it and uh you saved the Pazuki for
him and we split into two pieces so he
got to eat one on each day and he was
super stoked about that too he was
pretty stoked so the fact that you
remember that and you you were able to
slow down enough to know we had the
pizuki anything that made him really
happy and he wasn't just here's a Pazuki
he earned it you know like he crushed it
uh basketball crashed it at Jiu Jitsu so
you earned any of the green cards during
school so he earned both bazookies yeah
thank you okay so you kill the net this
week so we're Friday what did you kill
it at
um
or home run is the word oh yeah yeah so
what was your home run of the week
your home run of the week was or yeah
was
um
making sure that we were all eating
really good food
like um you just make it a point to
obviously cater to your diet but for you
you can eat the same shitty food no
flavor like day in and day out yeah you
know and yeah you'll have your like
desires of like oh my taste buds are
craving this and whatever Cravings you
may have but you always make sure that
like we get the Gourmet of whatever it
is that you're making
so you pay attention to what my dietary
restrictions are and then you give me
the best cuts of the meat
um you give me the warmest plates
um always I always serve myself last
bikini
I know I'm gonna start my period because
I always get so I want to cry
all the time every time I'm about to be
on my period I'm always like oh but
that's so happy and I want to cry all
these happy tears I'm the worst excuse
me oh I hate it no I did my makeup today
are you kidding me I'm fine
um yeah and then with taika you know he
has to have his food a specific way
right like so for eating meat you make
sure he gets it in his bowl and you cut
it up and there's enough ratio of carbs
to veggies to protein because he has to
have a well-balanced diet because he's a
growing boy and we want to keep him
healthy because he's taking these
unfortunate chemicals you know
because of his condition I want to build
his little muscles yeah and then and
that's cool who knows what the hell he's
eating right whatever peanut butter
jelly sandwiches every single day or
whatever so or he's just eating a bag of
chips we can't control that so what I
can control is nighttime so I'm like as
long as he has one good hearty
well-balanced meal high protein lots of
veggies then you know lunch time it's
him time yeah go off yeah yeah and uh
and at the beginning of his school year
they ask for there's like a supply list
where you give them like they want
pencils dreamwing folders and that one
of them is snacks and then it'll be like
enough snacks for like 20 something kids
and when so taika entered
um mid-school year to this new school so
uh I was like okay I don't think a lot
of parents are considering
like what we're considering in terms of
like you know sugar levels and like the
nutrition that we want them to have in
higher protein versus all this other
crap
so um I'm like man I bet they have like
the good snacks like the Pringles and
the Cheez-Its and the golden
what are they called fish gold goldfish
goldfish
um and they have all like the sweet
snacks animal crackers all of that
you know yeah the good good you know
what I'm saying the good good
um so when I was buying the snacks too I
made sure to get like the healthy
version of it without being like the
disconnect from kids version or
something like the Auntie whatevers so
they'll have like the Goldfish but then
the healthiest alternative which is
really not even the healthiest but
is like the bunnies you know what I'm
talking about I think so okay yes I got
that for him
um so yeah that's you killed it at this
week and as like we're eating it like
you're the one eating out of a
Tupperware like eating the leftover meat
because you don't want it to go to waste
and I'm like God damn it that's so
cute
um yeah because I want you guys to have
the fresh stuff so if there's something
that's like a dare to um I'll just eat
on the bed anyways yeah no I think
that's CUNY
you see it well I see it I don't know
Tiger's going dude
a little bubbles I don't I don't know if
you recognize I really liked what I made
last night oh the stew yeah how do you
know because he uh he's like succeed
when I like it I eat fast that's what he
said yeah I missed it and I gave him a
lot usually I give them this much but
then you know stews it's kind of
deceiving when it's separate so I put a
little bit rice and I put like meat in
there whatever and then by the time I
pour the broth it grew yeah I was like
holy moly and I chopped it all up and
there's all kinds of like good stuff
like carrots mushrooms onions all that
and then uh he was just scarfing it down
like it was nothing like he really likes
stews like that do we still have some
left yeah yeah yeah so you're gonna hook
them up again yeah
yeah he really really liked it so I'm so
happy yeah so that week uh for this week
you you killed it at that for sure and
um the other thing you killed it out is
anytime I make a suggestion about how we
can better our relationship like you
immediately want to apply it so one of
the other things that this guy
um
dads who try mentioned he was like do
the seven seven rule right remember I
told you that this week yeah I remember
already you were like yeah let's start
right now
um so the seven seven rule is every
seven days you take a you go on a little
date yeah you and your wife for you and
your significant other go on a little
date every seven weeks you do like an
overnighter trip so like we can go and
re-rent a hotel room at I don't know at
the Aria for the weekend
um and then every seven months every
seven months you take a vacation
and I'm like oh that's CUNY so
when I said that you were like hey let's
do we'll have our little date night like
coming up man I think that like you just
killed it like you're just so attentive
to
um
like my needs one and then two is you're
always down to make the adjustments or
changes like immediately well also no if
you don't make the changes chances are
it doesn't change yeah like you have to
like that's what I realized at least
about myself maybe it's ADHD or whatever
but I noticed that about everyone if
someone goes like hey you should sign up
for like or should buy Bitcoin for
example if they don't buy it right then
and there chances are it's never gonna
happen so you might as well yeah because
life happens yeah it's like okay if we
want to do this do let's do it right now
yeah and then that way you have one rep
in the books and then whatever you have
a muscle memory it's easier to come back
later you know yeah
CUNY so that's where you killed it this
week thank you
uh so the next one is base hit right so
what is something that uh you or I I
guess consistently kill it at
consistently kill it at I would say you
consistently kill it at
um so I think right now like in the
whole conversation of transitioning you
um more out of the business stuff and
then more into the mom stuff I I see you
consistently having these bass hits of
removing yourself and getting into there
so for example
um I think now
with the business I think you're doing
like not the bare minimum in terms of
like having a negative connotation but I
think doing the filling the gaps that's
needed for the business to run but
letting other people stand on their own
two feet in that way in that bare
minimum which is good because you're
allowing people to develop the skills
that they can Thrive well yeah and
that's the way you should run a business
yeah so there's that and then I also see
you uh also handle all the actual
because I know you want to be the CEO of
the family that kind of stuff you know
so like making sure
um the pool is progressing like in the
communication of that
um are there like getting a credit card
with other points so we can travel with
that so like you moving the little
notches and really being the CEO of the
family like what what like our rental
properties
um and also like getting like cleaning
up the finances so it's easier to
transition and the business stuff like I
really see you going Notch by notch
Notch by notch like moving everything
because we have that goal of like uh end
of March you're gonna be full-time mom
and I see you having these really
consistent basics of getting there
thanks yeah yeah I'm trying I'm trying
to uh
because I know that I'm Gonna Leave a
hole when I leave I'm trying my very
best to leave it
on a high note like I don't wanna I
would feel so bad if I walk away from
something that's drowning you know I'm
like how the can I even
say I can afford this luxury of me
stepping away when when like my whole
team needs me like I would feel like a
complete to do that so it just
feels like it's my obligation to
obviously strengthen my team
um have them feel supported put the
right players in positions
um and then I would feel really really
good walking away because I'm like yes I
did I did my job like I did what I had
to do
um and then with like the the at home
CEO like I'm so stoked I'm so
excited for that like that's all I ever
really wanted to do and it's so funny
like where life took me and it's like
and it's like it took me doing all of
these things for decades I'd be like
yeah no that's not really my thing like
that's not really like I don't want to
do any of that like my calling is still
coming back home I I really admire you
for that because I think a lot of people
think they know what they do without
testing it
and for you it's almost as if you got a
black belt in Jiu Jitsu and then you're
like Jiu Jitsu is not for me
you know what I mean that's
funny because a lot of people know
they're like what there's a lot of
people a lot of people yeah a lot of
people are like well just look at Jiu
Jitsu and not even doing well that's not
for me I was like well how do you know
you didn't even try it you haven't even
put in the
um the work to even start earning the
golden nuggets of the ROI of the Jiu
Jitsu and then for you it's not like
okay I tried it for a year of white belt
you like literally got the black belt in
business like you can start any business
you want from the ground up now and
you're like you know what that's not for
me and I really admire you for that
because you stuck it through and now
you've gained all these tools yeah which
um in the next chapter of our life I
only see exponential gains from it
because the ability to run a good
business is also very parallel to the
ability to run a good family yeah like
there's budgeting there's finances
there's what's the mission of the people
management all people yeah people
management are we trying to spend more
time together what type of time what
type of quality time are we trying to
have people imagine like the HR portion
hey second we gotta talk you know you've
been uh you've been squeezing papa's
butt a little bit too much you know
excuse me like you know that's it popped
up it's very very similar you know it's
very very similar but with family
there's a lot of more um cloudiness but
with the clear-cut vision of a business
and you apply it to family it's not that
cloudy and you can make the hard
decisions like that you know yeah
absolutely absolutely and and like I
just see it more as like Tech is my
business right now you know and and not
to make it sound cold but yeah literally
that you know whatever tools I have
acquired over the over the decade of
doing what I've been doing with like
producing and management and like
operations and like building the whole
business you know from a ground up like
all of that is super applicable yeah so
even going back to the basics of like
one one of our complicated situations is
taika's Nero is in La his Pharmacy is in
Nevada you know that he have to have
like legalities and insurance that cross
state lines and you even moving those
things forward it's not a simple like oh
yeah we'll just go to here it's like you
have to find the right plan yeah that
suits not only us but also him and also
our very unique situation yeah well to
even consider even going to another
State I don't think a lot of people
consider like yeah you know where
it's like well this is all I have like
these are my resources where it's like
no nothing like that in life is I mean
if business saw me anything it's
literally nobody's knows what the
they're doing and it all works yeah you
know if you have a solid Vision
on something you do it you can you can
uh yeah you can make it happen yeah if
you need to get stem cells in another
country yeah you go do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um thanks yeah no I'm I'm super stoked
for this new chapter in life and it
feels like a new chapter in life like I
don't
the other time I had this feeling of
like damn this is a new chap
there is when I entered college right
because it's an obvious yeah change not
not even uh when you quit your job to do
JK that's pretty big too
um
it didn't feel leaving a nine to five no
it didn't feel like a big life change
because I didn't know what was to come
right like it was just fun
um
like this one just feels like a huge
life change for me wow yeah because it's
like everything I've been doing for the
past decade that's it I'm stopping it
in that way
um and now I'm focusing because you have
elementary school middle school high
school college and then
work yeah yeah yeah but but call it from
high school to college was a huge
transition for me that was the other the
other time I thought because you're on
your own now or ish yeah because it's
like now I'm really an adult you know
now I have like my freedom AKA my car I
was still living with my parents but I
knew this was the beginning of some
different type of like life that I was
about to Embark like I was about to
enter an experience
you know everything prior to that was
very um structured like I like I didn't
I could have my brain off because I just
knew what the next steps were like I
didn't have to think about anything oh
that was the opposite
for me college I knew
what I almost know what the pipeline is
like from
undergrad grad PhD I knew that too I'm
like oh this is just a continuation so
to me like college was never like that
big of a deal
um
it was different for me because I had
freedom now oh you know like I got to
create my schedule I got to pick the
classes I wanted when I wanted to go to
school like that was the most amount of
freedom I ever had my whole life and
it's not that much freedom but to me it
was huge huge yeah you just never had it
so I just knew that was the beginning of
the rest of my life like that was the
first time I'm like I'm in control of
this like I'm paying my own way
I'm doing my own now like this is
me this is all you Geo so that was the
first time I felt my the chapters you
know yeah beginning and you trapped
their beginning
when it came to JK
um
I had already been working you know
um I had money saved up I knew my fives
are different from absolutely but I
didn't feel like there was much at risk
and I'm not saying that that a chapter
like a new chapter is about to begin
when there's a lot of risk but for this
one it didn't feel like there was much
of a shift happening because it just
felt like a continuation of like this
newfound Freedom that I have it was more
of Freedom you know what I mean yeah
because the first one was part of my old
life where I was really controlled and
it was this pipeline of like you go to
college and then you have the job and
then you get married and then you have
the house and then you have the kids
you know that was a path that I knew and
that I was told and that's the only way
to do it so then when I cut away from
that I'm like oh even more freedom I
knew there was more I knew it
you know so there wasn't a shift for me
it was just like what I've been wanting
I see for me for JK it was so huge
because
um
if you don't commit like a crime or a
major strike you technically get paid
the same at a nine to five so you could
do a bad job you could do a good job and
you generally get paid the same and it's
pretty consistent so to me it's almost
like school you know like you the tracks
are laid on the ground and the railroad
goes on the tracks and you can just do
that 20 years and then you'll get some
sort of retirement and pension and
you're good
doing JK
a good a good video versus a bad video
could be a difference between like a
thousand dollars that month or 1500 that
month and you could have spent like 80
hours on a bad video and 10 hours
on a good video so it has nothing to do
with hourly wages how much effort you
put in it's just the result and because
like me and Joe were looking at the
AdSense like especially early on it was
so scary because you don't want to
channel your energies in the wrong place
yeah and put in 80 hours to make a bad
video yeah and then like let's say our
costs were a thousand bucks that month
then if you made only 800 we're
so to me I think being like
um having all that pay
lying on my shoulders it was like oh
this is something different this is
something different you know yeah yeah I
guess I was fortunate where because JK
is in my business I didn't give a
about that and
um this is what I was saying was I
already had my savings I knew what my
cost of living was I knew how long I
could live off of that comfortably
um so I wasn't worried about that before
I moved out I had my parents blessing
which was wild that I never in a million
years thought I would have my dad's like
hey if you can't make it you can always
come back you know it wasn't something
that I was like cool like I can go back
whenever I want like that wasn't even a
consideration but just knowing that that
safety net is there gave me extra
um
uh Comfort if you will it was like very
comforting to know that you know so
um and then not looking at the algorithm
and having it go up and down like I
didn't give a like if there was no
money coming like I I just felt like I
was progressing so much and learning so
much that
that was it was just worth it because
I'm like man this is tight you
know like and it wasn't tight because
I'm just hanging out with friends it's
like we're learning a bunch of like
I was I had my hands in so many
different aspects of a business it was
so cool
um and and I think I've just always
naturally liked
some type of Commerce or business or
something because like you know the
stories of me like having
um you know I was like five or seven or
some and I'm like slanging my
toys with the art like on a yard
sale or I would go to Costco and buy
candy you know so I could slang it at
school and get a little bit of a profit
from it like I just I that's just
naturally in me to want to like
I don't know if it's the building part
of things or just running my own
um
so when I was able to run my own on
someone else's dime that was tight so
yeah that's why I didn't feel like and
you dropped it for me oh I see yeah but
this right now feels like a new chapter
because it feels like I'm embarking in
like I'm not embarking on something but
it just feels like
this new adventure is about to start and
I have no idea where it's going yeah
because you're also letting work go
completely 100 which is something you've
never done before and I know I'm not
gonna let it go because I I
create things I'm a Creator you
know yeah yeah so I can already see
myself diving into our personal and
like building that up where I can see
myself
diving more into tiger and building
him up even more you know like
I know I'm not I I'm not a I'm not a
stagnant person yeah you're not gonna be
the drink wine and watch soap operas
before yeah like I'm not gonna be
sitting on the couch you know while my
son's at school yeah like I knew I'm
gonna be doing a bunch of and I'm
stoked
um and I and I like the fact that
I don't really know what to expect
I think that's fun
um
I'm not really scared about anything I'm
not really like oh gotta gotta watch out
about this
um but I have already adjusted my
behavior to be more like
um
like
I don't want to my I'm like in a
different mindset like I'm more of an
investing mindset right now too whereas
before
um when we were like in our 20s it was
more of like let's experience whatever
that means let's just experience
everything
um money isn't an issue not that money
is an issue now but just where I'm at
like I still want to experience things
but it's not at this heightened level of
like let's just jump off a
building let's see what traveling the
world is for 24 hours or
whatever you know whereas now it's more
so like slow it down what's really
important and invest in that so whether
that's
um the relationship building the
community building my son us you know
training my dog like I just want to
invest myself and time and money in in
things that are actually super important
and are going to pay off in the in the
long run for me yeah that's where I'm at
Miss CUNY
yeah so I'm super stoked it's a new
chapter and it feels it feels kidney
what did I do for my base hits
um something you're consistent at
it doesn't matter what's on your plate
or how stressful work gets or what the
workload is like or what's happening in
your life you're very consistent person
in terms of moods So like
um if you're a business guy you're
focused on the business guy part of it
for however long that is right so if you
say today I'm going to be the business
guy until 6 p.m once 601 hits you if you
know when a dog gets hurt they don't go
like they don't like sit there and like
they mope the whole time they just shake
it off yeah yeah and they're like happy
again yeah you know so it's like when
601 hits for you you shake it off and
now you're like that's it business
it never existed yeah I'm out yeah yeah
you know
um and now you're 100
present with taika you know you're 100
dad doesn't matter how tired I'm
like damn how the does he do it
like I don't know how you're able to cut
it off
because for me I tend to carry you know
anything that's happening that's
stressing me out from work I'm still
trying to either problem solve or I'm
like how am I gonna get through
this or how am I going to resolve this
and it's like I carry my stress with me
the whole day until I can solve it or
fix it
um but for you it's like if it ain't
burning down I don't give a it's
family time yeah and I think that's like
super solid you've always kind of been
that way and like you've never brought
any stress or like any bad mood into the
new thing you're in so like if I mean
you're not really a moody person either
but if you so happen to be a little bit
more on edge that day because of
whatever might be happening again once
601 hits and work is over that's it it's
like nothing else exists you're happy go
lucky now everything's out the window
yeah I realized um if I take things into
other things I don't do a good job
so I almost treat it like um
kind of like uh like an improv show
you know like when you get on stage
someone gives you suggestion there's a
scene you and your scene partner could
be brothers and sisters boom next It
Could Be Cops and Robbers boom it could
be doctor patient and if you bring in
the other stuff then you're not really
like present and immersed in the scene
and the scene's not good
so I think like that's kind of how I
view it where like but how do you shake
it off
I don't know how to shake it off I think
it's the same way as jumping into a cold
pool you just have to do it and I think
the more you do it the shake off time is
shorter and shorter and shorter oh I see
so now it's just like you know some
other people like if they people that
Skydive it's no brainer they could
literally talk to you and just fall
backwards right versus the new guys
dudes like okay what
two they need the countdown you know and
I think for me I've done it for so long
and I've also been through so many
circumstances where I realized
things don't burn down in one day
so yes even then the craziest
emergencies
um sometimes you need something within
the hour but even if you don't get it
within the hour like uh like for example
it's really really important is every
time we have a launch for Barlow Brigade
all hands on deck at that time right and
if the website crashes it's a huge deal
all hands on deck everyone tries to
troubleshoot within that hour but
zooming out a little bit is one launch
gonna crush the year's business not
really so I've just been through so much
of different fires to like if I really
zoom out and I go okay this is my life
in this decade
is this one thing gonna crumble my
fatherhood or is it gonna crumble my
business or gonna crumble my
relationship with my mom if not
then I you can wait till tomorrow so
because I know that the true consequence
in aftermath isn't that detrimental if I
wait till tomorrow then right now I can
just be in it here with whoever and give
them my hundred percent because I also
realize when I give my 100 that's when I
had like my biggest reward like even
when I uh was uh recently selling my
dad's car and my mom wanted to come and
tag along like
I wasn't really on Instagram or anything
like that I was just with my mom and
just talking as if like no phones
existed and were able to kind of push
our relationship a little bit more and
have a little bit more understanding you
know because that's one of my goals of
this year is to like rekindle my
relationship with my mom yeah so I
really try to you know even though I'm
there like which is Kindle it just kind
of yeah just trying to Kindle just
Kindle that yeah and I also know
it's uh one thing I also learned um
is
with your relationship it's also not
fair to bring in your other
yeah it's not fair like with with uh
taika like he comes home he doesn't know
like how many fires I put out he doesn't
know I woke up at 4am to train he
doesn't know any of that he just
goes Papa you know you know what I
learned I learned George Washington is
the first prisoner of the United States
he doesn't say president yet yeah so
like if I can go oh boy just tell me
later papa needs a nap or you know
Papa's like whatever bled over it's
unfair to him so he comes at me I give
it to him a hundred percent and then the
back and forth sometimes is so good you
forget what other you had you
forget you're tired or you forget what
you're whatever you know I really try to
like snap at him and snap out of it like
try to like treat it like jet lag you
know you could be jet lag sleeping in a
hotel or you could really try to see the
city you're in and like
soak it all up as much as you can yeah
so that's my that's my mentality at
least yeah you're really good at that
and then it's like when it comes to
playing right like I know you're
exhausted but yeah you I see it it's a
hundred percent you're like just as
energetic as tyke and I'm like how the
is this guy doing this right now
because I'm like crawling because I'm
just so mentally drained I'm
like and I see you like
and I'm like
I suck
yeah you're so good try to and then even
at night when that's over and I'm like
okay I'm tired as but it's time to
you know I'm like put on you better
put my pants on because I don't
give a that I'm tired since I was 4
a.m did all the work played with taika
my wife needs to be pleasured oh God you
know so I tried to and then sleep time
and then you know you always get a
chance to recharge or whatever so I try
to give every scene
yeah damn no that's that's that's been
consistently you since I've known you
've never wavered from any of that like
if you're present doing that thing
you're doing that thing a hundred
percent
like there's yeah it's nuts like
you just zero in on that and I'm
like God damn that's intense it's really
dope I wasn't at Tony Robbins like uh we
took a business seminar and I don't
remember where I kind of learned this
phrase but it kind of validated a way
that I've already been treating my life
but it was pretty much saying like if
you're present like really present your
future is taken care of people think
they need to plan their futures
but you don't
I mean it's good to have a general
um
but if you're truly present
your future is taken care of so for
example like um like let's say I'm here
with you right and we're having a dinner
if I'm truly present I'm talking with
you that this moment and then every
single moment that's just like this that
comes up is what's gonna give us a very
healthy loving happy 20-year of marriage
right the next time that my friend talks
to me about investing or real estate or
whatever if I'm truly present and I act
in that moment you know what you're
right I should start putting 200 bucks
away a month or whatever and I literally
do it right then and there I set up the
auto pay the way whatever
I don't need to think about oh am I
going to save the 10 grand that I need
yeah it's gonna happen like because all
of it sounds like some Jordan Peterson
because all of us
um I think all of us experience
at least one facet of our life that we
need that and that we're trying to build
in the future so whether it's a
relationship Finance Health whatever
like if you go man I should probably
walk and if you're really in that
present moment then go walk and you do
that walk and the next time you have
that thought you go do it that if you
really truly present it'll take care of
the 20 years later and because of like
that really clicked when I heard that I
was like dude I should just be that
really truly like present person yeah
because I think people think the
opposite they think they have to plan
then they set such a lofty goal that the
present becomes so hard to do and they
feel like they're dragging their feet
versus just be like the present person
you know like oh shoot
yeah I'll turn my dog how to sit for
like 10 minutes right now yeah and then
they end up being a very obedient dog
yeah
this CUNY I like that yeah that's so
true
yeah you hit me with it where I'm like
yeah
yeah it is if you're present you're
literally building your future like yeah
if you're truly present yeah you really
take care of your future if you're truly
present yeah but if you're not
like let's say you're like oh uh I
think I need an oil change I'll just put
it off
because you want to go back to thinking
about what your other thoughts you know
I was daydreaming about this
yeah you you really won't because I
think we're we're like we have this
subconscious level of like
responsibility that the stuff that we
need to do will come
and if we just treat each one the way it
should like cool it's lunch time be
truly present
what was I trying to do when I'm trying
to be like uh what I want to eat oh I
wanted to be on a diet could truly be
present instead of going on Yelp now or
do whatever yeah then you'll eat clean
most of the time
I gotta be more present I gotta work on
that right now I feel like I'm
all over the place yeah I see myself
like
leaving things open or unfinished and I
see like a thing that I started here but
didn't finish and I've I think it's at
an extreme right now where I'm looking
at it I'm going what the slow down
I think I'm not present at all right now
I don't know what the is happening
I think I just have too many things in
my mind and I need to get it out
yeah yeah you might see I see myself
like kind of scattered everywhere what
if you uh take notes on stuff because
that helps me out
like every Department of my life I have
notes so like if you look at my notebook
I'll have like a finance and these are
some things even things that I know I
need to do later on uh like I want to
look into crypto again or look into like
uh stocks or something I'll write that
stuff down
and then I'll write like uh what's my
personal errands like garage I clean the
garage it's in there so that I just have
it because I if I if I don't take it out
it's just like a blender and then that's
when I feel I realize I'm not present
but the minute I take it out and I kind
of have like my mental desktop if you
will yeah there's like my 20 categories
anywhere from errands to
putting wrapping my truck in matte black
because I still want to do that to
working out through everything
I have it all so that I don't constantly
have these stupid ruminating thoughts I
couldn't want to wrap my car when I'm
gonna wrap my I'm gonna go shooting I'm
gonna go scuba diving that's me right
now yeah I gotta write that down
yeah I have it all written down and then
that little quotes out of my brain now
I'm present and then when there is free
time boom I open my notebook oh cool
what are some how do I prioritize these
things and that's why like the like two
weeks ago I was able to go shooting
because I was like oh yeah I do have a
window of opportunity I can't go
shooting won't mess anything up that's
something I wanted to do at least once a
quarter check that off
and then when I'm shooting I'm like I'm
there guilt-free
because I was I I looked at my schedule
I knew I could do it and then so I was
there a hundred percent I wasn't working
and then yeah yeah that is CUNY yeah
I'll probably do that okay the last and
final question where did I struck out
this week like where did I drop the ball
struck out
this is the hard one
I think it's an easy one for me oh
it always is no we talk about Geo
it always no this one it's it's well
it's kind of takes two to tango but this
one's a sexy times one
I know we're trying to like have some
sexy times and also make some siblings
you know what I'm saying
so I dropped the ball on that that's
where I struck out um well I think
because
I am capable of it's time
I also want to gauge where you're at so
the minute I hear you go
[Music]
tired I'm like okay I understand you
know so I don't try to like press or try
to do so I don't know if that's a me
striking out because it does take two to
tango well because it takes two to tango
I've also felt the
heart eyes all dinner you know and then
and then we sleep or uh
or uh I come I come out of the shower
and I'm like what's all this fragrance
everywhere you know like I can tell when
you're trying I see so it's uh when we
do the 50 50 and you meet me halfway
um we're ready to go so the times that
it doesn't happen is if you're not doing
50. because if you do 50 I'll always do
50. I'm always down to do 50. yeah yeah
yeah so if you don't bring the other 50
then I'm like oh she's tired of like a
lot a lot of stuff happened today so I'm
like that's fine so obviously that's
where he struck out where he did bring
your 50. this is my my pants yeah
and have my pants yeah yeah man
it's so hard like um
yeah like sex is one of the last things
on my mind and then it's one of those
things where I'm like but we have to
it's a responsibility now right so now
it's becoming this thing where it's like
I have to put on my to-do list
you know like now it's one of these
things I have to to do
me is having a dream I think she's
running in a dream
um but yeah if I struck out I struck out
you know that's it I'll try to be more
uh and this is not something new like we
talk about this all the time but it's
just it's just hard like I just
have to learn to be present and I gotta
learn to like do the ice bath method of
just like once something's done you
close that for the day and you start
this new one you give it your 100 I
think it's literally just being present
and then also if we could build a
routine around it yeah
it's helpful you know the people that
like can't sleep at night
it's because uh that's like 100 miles an
hour and then they go in bed and then
they're like it's like trying to get the
airplane to come to full stop yeah yeah
yeah yeah versus like okay unwinding
lowering this is my life yeah like from
eight to nine is when I unwind you know
take a hot bath dim the lights exactly
drink some chamomile tea uh listen to
music that's not too stimulating or
whatever and then by nine you're you're
alley-ooped yourself you know but if I'm
doing all that baby I'm Gonna Knock Out
well what I'm saying is maybe we need
our routine yeah you know like
drink some Angry Orchard
little winky Winks you know and then
like and then uh
maybe we we do like we touch each other
from the back like mutual masturbation
but whose hands are these I don't know
are these strangers and then we build a
routine into it so that it doesn't feel
like
um I'm a mom and then now I gotta
because that's probably really hard
that's what it feels like that's
probably really really hard you know
because it goes I'm a business owner to
now I'm a mom now I gotta yeah I
mean that's extremely hard
yeah exactly it's extremely hard yeah
because even I'm like that you know like
when I'm like
I just made food so I'm like a
chef
and then like right after I'm like okay
wash dishes all right time to it's
hard too but I think I've just been able
to be more
um ice bath like you said yeah where I'm
able to like just kind of jump into it a
little bit more yeah and I'm a little
bit more present I think I think maybe
for you like worried about a bunch of
stuff but I think we're practice being a
little bit more present just being there
yeah I think it'll be fine and we build
a little routine to kind of just help
Grease the Grease the grooves so it just
slides in where it needs to oh God oh
God yeah got it
um where did I strike out I've been
thinking about this the whole time
and uh more proof that I'm not present
but
um
it's funny I've been thinking about it
the whole time we were talking and I
don't know if I'm making excuses for you
and it's because I understand and I just
don't know how to express myself no no
no no no I would say it if I that's I'm
just saying I can't find anything and
this is I'm giving you the reasons as to
why I think I can't find anything and
it's not because you're perfect I mean
Kobe don't miss shut the up you're
really good you're really good right so
one of the things is I'm like
um there is this like
I I feel it I don't know if you feel it
but every time you leave to California
when you come back it feels like you
kind of have to like get back into the
groove of like our family again yeah
yeah yeah
um yeah for sure you feel that yeah
that's CUNY I mean it's not CUNY but
yeah so so I think it's CUNY that we
both feel it yes I think that's what I
was saying
um so there's that re-establishing of
like what the the our routine is and now
you kind of have to like slowly make
your boy back into it and it's wild
right because it's you're only gone for
maybe like four days max like four days
is an extreme but even if it's two days
it feels like that that's crazy to me
because it's like when you're here it's
like
yeah it's just it's different yeah
um so with that re-establishing your
relationship back into our family I feel
like that happens with us too where it's
like because I know you're working you
know because you're filming literally
back to back like multiple videos and
when you're in California you're never
there to play like it's never like I'm
going hang out with my friends you know
if if you do so happen to hang out with
them it's because you guys were just
working together and now you're just
having dinner yeah you know
um or it's because you're filming a
Content around whatever so it feels like
when you come back not only does that
happen with our family Dynamic but it
also feels like it happens with us too
where we kind of have to like
re-establish that like we're together
you know because then we go back right
it straight into work mode or straight
into parenting mode and then we're so
exhausted
um and I know you're exhausted because
you've been traveling or whatever that I
just try to back off from anything so
I'm like I just want to give you your
space because I know like because I
understand that you need to come back
into this routine you know because it's
such a bummer when I'm like dude I could
do miss Papa and Papa and Tech is like
no and it's not because he doesn't miss
you but it's because he's just like
sleeping with one of us
um but even things like that I'm like oh
man what a bummer like that must feel
like to like come home and even hear it
like I know you know he doesn't mean it
but just like hearing it and so I think
too much for you yeah I don't think
about any of that stuff okay well
me well because I'm present
so when he says no I'm like oh I know
exactly why I asked yeah yeah well I'm a
loser okay so like I really try
to cater to
what I've seen you've been through and
kind of just give you your space that in
giving that space I give us space you
don't need to because my glove pants I
mean my pants
glove pants yeah they're literally am I
glove compartment so when I get out of
the car I could put them on why don't
you always wear them and then as
soon as you see me just go and tear off
the work ones and then the love
pants already on because you're not
ready to have the pants on okay
fine yeah but it feels like that so um
so because of that
that's what I'm saying like I don't know
if you've struck out you know like
because it's more so like I understand
the situation and why things are playing
out the way that they are because right
now we're in this big transition of
things yeah so I can't say
that there is this area where you struck
out this week yeah and Kobe don't miss
shut the am I gotta think of
something
where did this the
strike out
um
I'm also not picky you know what I mean
like my standards are pretty low I don't
think so
I know I really don't think you struck
out anywhere yeah I mean has there been
other weeks where I struck out Maybe
maybe I mean yeah but it's not anything
that sticks out where I'm like that's
the thing you know like I
um kind of to your base hits and your
home runs you're a pretty consistent
person when it comes to giving things
you're 100 and I see the effort and I
see even if you even if the effort falls
short I saw that the effort was put in
that like that just makes up for it you
know yeah
um
so I can't say that I feel that anything
was struck out where I'm like man you
dropped the ball on that
yeah if I see effort to me that's
already a base hit so if I see you like
get all dolled up and put on lingerie
and then I could go to sleep and you're
like Daddy should try I honestly I would
I'd be like should try
she tried really hard okay yeah got it
yeah we fell asleep with like the
blanket over your stomach and your
pussy's all out I'm like oh she really
tried
you know I wouldn't
like it just on my stomach I get cold
that's you dude yeah no I there's
nothing that you struck out you're
really a great partner oh thank you like
I can see you know you try to maintain
the cleanliness of the house or like
when you're cooking you try to maintain
that or you constantly check in with me
or you're sharing whatever it is that
you're doing or watching and like you
give me an affection like it just feels
like you're very balanced everywhere
I wanted to talk too
I try hard but I also think I could
still be more present
because I catch myself like you know
when Mia comes and like nudges me
I'm like when I'm I'm a a game I give
her the love and I play with it for a
good five minutes you know and then like
that's present with her but then if my
mind's on track on something else then
she comes then I'm like oh I'm gonna
move then it becomes like a nuisance but
then it's it's not fair yeah yeah yeah
that's cutie yeah because it's not like
she's trying to like bug me all day long
yeah you know she only comes in only a
few times yeah she does a cute little
aggressive bump with her nose like she
pushes like she knows like like you know
she's there with that bump yeah she's
sleeping on the floor right now now
these are great questions and I can see
how this really does develop a really
great strong sight a solid line of
communication if both partners are
willing to be very uh open to anything
that comes out of their partner's mouth
and willing to listen for the sake of
bettering and not taking it as a
critique and like a personal attack on
like their character I like the striking
out part because
um
those are the ways you can help make the
relationship better of course I mean and
it's also good to talk about the home
runs because that's also a way to make
it better and I also like that ratio too
where it's like two good things to one
needs Improvement
you know because it's if you play the
needs Improvement game too much then
you're no longer a team and it's more
about defense and offense and I think
you win by having a good offense you
know like yeah what did you do good what
did I do good and do we see that as good
and then okay but what are the one
things that yeah but as much as we like
focusing on the things that we can
improve I also have always considered
this and always thought about this and
this is how I really do love running my
businesses
um is that like we also really need to
highlight the things that are good yeah
because if we don't highlight the things
that are good then we don't know that
they're
we might think that they're good for us
but because we're not in a relationship
with ourselves we don't know that the
other person views it that way or
receives it that way or or even uh views
it at all yeah yeah yeah so the fact
that they're able to point that out and
you're like oh my God that's so cool
because that's literally what I'm trying
to do then you do that thing more and
then you get better at doing the good
thing yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah
um versus the traditional like you're
never home were you ungrateful because
I'm out there making yeah yeah like
that yeah it's like you do they're
having two different conversations yeah
and then shows you that your partner's
paying attention and and seeing the good
that you're doing yeah because they're
highlighting it for you it's not you
boasting about you know how great you
are it's the other person boasting on
your behalf and I think that's really
rad
um but this is a really cool exercise I
like it hopefully we can do it every
week is there something you're proud of
yourself this week that you did proud of
myself because if I were to add a fourth
question that's what I would add because
I think it's also important to like I
should say like validate yourself yeah
because sometimes your partner might be
might not be seeing
uh eye to eye and then it might be good
to help the partner to see like oh
that's what's important to them too you
know
um I'm proud of myself this week that
um I've been able to
at least with taika have more patience
um
because I am trying to be more present
that I'm trying to allow myself and
remind myself kind of we had this
conversation on the previous uh last
week's podcast of like
um you know figuring out when to be a
parent versus a friend and stuff and
like for us we tend to want to be more
in the middle you know we're like
um we understand that we're parenting
because he's so young but we also really
want to be his friend and not in the
sense of like let him let him get away
with whatever because we want him to
like us but friend because we want to
nurture and help see him grow and like
reach his full potential like that's a
good friend if you have if you don't
have friends that try to do that to
you you need new friends
um so like
with taika just making sure that I can
have that balance because when I notice
when I'm trying to parent more I have
such a short temper because I like
there's these expectations and these
things that I want him to hit and
there's a way that I want him to behave
and answer and just and talk and do his
homework and like uh be presentable like
there's just so many rules and
restrictions when it comes to Parenting
him
that I know it could feel like very
heavy and like daunting on both ends
because I don't like it but I'm like
I need you to be a a
contributing member to this Society you
know so we both have this pressure
um and and I just need to learn to kind
of like find the balance there so I feel
like this week I've just had more
patience with that and just kind of
reminding myself like okay is this a
parenting moment or is this a moment
where you can just back the off and
it's not gonna like it's not gonna be a
detriment to take his future yeah that's
really difficult yeah yeah it's
really because it's very hard to like
um get out of yourself to see like oh
man you know because a lot of times like
we are our biggest supporters so
whatever we do we think we're right it's
Justified yeah of course I would do that
because of this but it's always cool to
like wait was that the best move for you
know what I'm trying to do and then
always having that like check in with
yourself moment you know yeah what's
yours
mine uh one of my most proud of uh this
week
I would say like since I kill it all the
time
I'm just kidding
me no I think mine is uh you're gonna
call me a bro or meat head for it
no it's um here we go
and to find the best way to balance
um dumbbell curls versus
no no trying to balance like
um
like my fitness goals were which are
just as important as barbell Brigade
goals so I'm like the center of a lot of
the series uh with my family and what
I'm trying to do
you know like uh
if I was just an athlete I don't have a
family and we're just like dating or
whatever I can go harder right like like
the UFC fighters the ones that don't
have kids yeah they're training
five six yeah they're in the gym eight
hours a day yeah understood makes sense
but you got family and you have kids and
you have a wife or whatever it's
different you know so like me trying to
like because right now it's also trying
to like uh look good as an athlete I
have my actual training my weights
but I also have to hit my steps and when
we're doing stuff like this I'm
literally not moving so I'm not going to
get lean so I need to move and trying to
find Pockets where things are uh where I
can like you know I went to Ikea we
walked we got a couple thousand steps
and also looked at some things we can
get for the house and um also yesterday
like let's watch some Netflix and bond
together while you're making something
for Titan I'm just marching in the room
you know yeah and I walked like three
miles in place because I walked for 45
minutes like in the room so like being
able to kind of like
um not have an excuse because I think
it's easy to have an excuse well like
how am I gonna like exercise when I have
all this family time or how am I gonna
have to spend time with the kids when I
have these big business goals me trying
to get creative and figure out a way how
I can accomplish both I think that's
what I'm pretty proud of that's CUNY
yeah Fitness is important so I
think I was just telling you this this
week where um I took about maybe a month
off of training just because there were
just so many things happening
um and I don't have the same pressure
not to say that this is why you're
training but I just don't have the same
um goals or deadlines or even pressure
to perform specific to like series or
YouTube or anything online
I do have the luxury to take some time
off and it doesn't affect anybody so um
I took a month off
and like I didn't realize how much I
missed it like how much it does to like
my mental health my physical health
um like just even eating like my
nutrition everything just was so
and it's like in relation to us
because we're pretty responsible people
but it was pretty
um and then once I got to training I'm
like God damn this is so essential like
I could never I could never have that
much time off from moving
um
um so I can see what you're where you're
coming from and it's not really
meatheadish it's like I think everyone
should feel this huge void in absence
when they're not being active because it
does so much like it puts you outside it
makes you eat better
um it still gives you energy to play
with your kids or be romantic you know
like it gives you stamina like it's
there's so many benefits to it
you know what I mean like your immunity
support is better like it's just end
this amount of benefits like it just
doesn't make sense not to want to find a
balance to put that in your in your life
yeah I'm trying to implement everything
even stuff I learned like Andrew
huberman's podcast you know trying to
get that low angle light uh sunlight in
the mornings at night so I try to time
my walks that way
you know just trying to like
um find a way where it seems like a lot
of the information we're given on how to
live a good life seems like they're
conflicting but I'm like there's got to
be a way to make it not and I try my
best to have it all Incorporated somehow
you know yeah that's CUNY
CUNY yeah I like this I like these um
hopefully you guys can find benefit in
doing it too and hopefully you guys get
to do this practice and if you do please
let me know how it like how it went uh
hit me up in my DMs or leave comments
you know down below I want to see how
how it turned out for you guys so
definitely try it out also shout outs
too
um that's who try I need to be better at
seeing what your name is but I
am going to watch more of your content
and I'll try to connect
um online with you because I I
love what you're doing and I think
you're killing it
um anything you want to add yeah uh
the undead collection is coming out soon
from borrow Brigade so I know a lot of
you guys have been super excited on
Instagram When we dropped the deadlift
tea and the skeleton uh squat T so look
uh stay tuned for that that is dropping
very soon along with our best on rebirth
hoodies so I know a lot of times we've
been stalking way more this year than
one of the biggest comments like oh man
you guys sell it so uh so soon so fast
we did stock more but don't wait because
these teas are hot so see you guys at
Barbara Brigade and see you guys next
time bye